thank you about we have just completed
the arraignment process wherein the
grand jury's indictment which included
two separate incidences was presented
before the court cuber entered a not
guilty plea and we ask that the court in
the interest of justice and to avoid
prejudice seven the two separate
incidences for trial and we actually
answered ready to proceed today with the
first incident for trial we are shocked
outraged and absolutely dumbfounded that
the district attorney's office has
wasted the taxpayers money resources at
time in charge in Cuba with these two
incredulous cases you have seen the
first case which is revealed in a
10-second video clip where Cuba is being
alleged to have groped a woman's breasts
yet the video does not reveal anything
along those lines and after over a
hundred and twenty days of trying to
develop a case having interviewed seven
different individuals gone through
twenty five hundred videos and
established a DNA assessment of the
alleged accusers dress which revealed
four different DNA's
district attorney was still unable to
proceed to trial and in order to avoid
the embarrassment of answering not ready
after over 120 days they used the really
employed technique of moving this
misdemeanor into a grand jury
proceedings and causing an indictment so
the case could be transferred to the
Supreme Court we then saw this morning
that they added one other accusers
charged to this indictment which is even
less credible than the first one and we
ask you the media to insist that the
district attorney release the video of
the second accuses claim which will once
again show that absolutely no criminal
conduct was engaged in by Cuba we are so
surprised that this case is going
forward and it is only indicative of the
hysteria and unusual environment and
climate that exists today to such an
extent that a commonplace gesture is now
perceived to be inappropriate and we
look for example to the incredible
condemnation of Vice President Joe Biden
for touching the shoulder of a woman we
ask that this case be moved quickly
because Cuba's life has been put on hold
for four months and the United States
Constitution
guarantees a speedy trial and we hope
that this case will be a hallmark case
for the not-me movement thank you are
you failing Cuba
[Music]